SPEAKER: Please join
me in giving a warm
welcome to Amanda Cohen.
[APPLAUSE]
AMANDA COHEN: Thank you for
that lovely introduction.
SPEAKER: Of course, Amanda.
Thanks so much for coming.
I know we're all really
excited to have you.
So let's just start about
learning a little bit more
about your background.
How did you know you
wanted to be a chef
and eventually open up a
restaurant and a cookbook?
AMANDA COHEN: I didn't
know any of that.
I still don't know if
I know any of that.
I'm not sure what I want
to do when I grow up.
I really loved cooking as a kid.
I'm from a really big family.
I have four older siblings.
And there's about a five-year
gap between my nearest
sibling to me in age.
And one day, all
my siblings sort of
ended up-- they
were all in college.
And my mom basically
turned to me and my dad
and was like, yeah, I'm done.
I'm not cooking anymore.
And we were like, OK.
My dad was like, yeah.
I guess I'll just have
lunch at the office.
I don't know what he did.
And I was like,
yeah, but I'm 13.
I've got to eat.
She was like, yeah.
You're gonna have
to figure it out.
And I did.
And I really liked to cook.
So every night after school,
I would go home and cook.
And I just fell in love with
that time in the kitchen
and how much fun it
was to play with food.
And then I sort of
forgot about it.
I went to college.
I came to New York.
I went to NYU.
I went through school.
I traveled a bunch afterwards.
I lived in Hong
Kong for two years.
I lived in LA for a year.
And I was really floundering.
And what I really
wanted to do in my life
was travel and not work.
But I realized that
nothing's free.
So I had to have a skill.
And I literally had no skills.
And I was like, well, maybe
if I go to cooking school,
I can travel with this skill.
And I like to cook enough.
So I'll learn how to cook.
And then I can go
anywhere in the world
and use this great
skill of mine.
So I came back to New York,
and I went to cooking school.
And I started
cooking in the city,
and I actually really
never traveled again.
I've been here ever since, and
that was about 20 years ago.
And even at that time,
as I was cooking,
I didn't know this
was my passion,
it's what I wanted to do.
I just liked it.
I like the culture in kitchens.
I really like sort of exploring
textures and flavors with food.
I like the hours.
I like the whole
crazy environment.
And I kept going and going
and going until one day,
I realized, oh, shit.
This is what I do.
I guess now 10
years into this, I
can call myself a
cook and a chef.
And then I had had a series of
jobs, some of which I liked,
some of which I hated.
But I kind of hit a
point in my career
where I couldn't go any further.
I had sort of stayed in
the vegetarian world.
And there weren't really any
other vegetarian restaurants
I could go cook at.
I had sort of cooked at
them all in the city.
And I had this
choice I had to make,
which was either stay
where I was in my career
or start back at the
beginning and be a line
cook in a mainstream restaurant,
cook a lot more meat,
rise through the ranks that way.
Or I could say, screw it all,
and start my own restaurant.
And I had actually kept
working for other people,
and then I kind of got
fired from a lot of jobs.
And I realized that,
oh, maybe my only option
is to work for myself
because obviously, I
don't like other bosses.
And so that's when I
opened the restaurant.
SPEAKER: Well, that's
an awesome story.
How was opening your
first restaurant?
Could you walk us through
what that really is like?
AMANDA COHEN: It's sort
of like going to hell
and never getting out of it.
And you think you're
at the last circle,
and then you discover
there's actually
an eighth circle of hell.
And that's just like the first
day of opening the restaurant.
It was really, really hard.
You think you know everything.
You're like, oh, I'll figure
this out as I go along.
But I've worked in
restaurants for long enough,
so I know how this works.
And as it turns out,
you know nothing.
And I've opened a
second restaurant since.
And the second time, I was
like, oh, I know everything.
I've got this under control.
And I'm still like, fuck.
How do I not know anything?
How do I keep screwing this
up over and over again?
They say that chefs
have really big egos.
I got to tell you,
though, opening
a restaurant will
just crush that
over and over and over again.
So the first one
was really hard.
It was small.
It was 350 square feet.
I had about maybe $300,000
was my budget, which,
350 square feet, it
sounds like a lot.
It sounds like it should be
the right amount of money.
I had an awful contractor.
He really, really
screwed us over.
He took all my money, basically,
and didn't do a lick of work,
and then we had to bring
in a second contractor.
And if you've ever
built anything,
you sort of know
that that's the worst
thing you can do because
then nobody has to take
responsibility for anything.
So when the plumbing goes
wrong, the second contractor's
like, oh, yeah.
Sorry, that's not my problem.
And you're like, yeah,
but you're my contractor.
And they're like, yeah, but
the first contractor put it in.
And you're like, ah.
All right.
And he's like, so, it's going
to cost, you know, $500,000.
And you're like, well,
I need a bathroom.
So, OK.
And the build that was
supposed to take three months,
it ended up taking a year.
And instead of
costing $300,000, it
cost us $700,000
for 350 square feet.
And the place was still crappy.
People would walk
in and be like,
what's this little craphole
in the Middle East Village?
And I'd be like, but it's
such an expensive craphole!
You can't say that!
It took me a year to
get the floors level.
And they'd be like, yeah, but
that's still rolling downhill.
Yeah, I know.
Well, I tried.
And then when we actually
opened, because everybody
had really sort of
not done their job,
we opened without gas.
And so we spent the first
six months without gas,
cooking on Easy-Bake appliances.
So we had a teeny-tiny
little grill,
a teeny-tiny little fryer.
Our oven was like
a toaster oven.
It wasn't even one of those-- I
don't know if anybody watches,
like, "Real Housewives
of New York"
where Sonya wants
[INAUDIBLE] her toaster oven.
It wasn't even a fancy
toaster oven like that.
It was really like
an Easy-Bake Oven.
And so we had to really
struggle through that.
And eventually, we got gas.
And we had sort of set
the restaurant up to fail.
And that's a really weird
way to write up a budget,
but I was like, I
don't know if anybody's
going to want to
come and eat my food.
We're going to do
vegetarian, but we're really
going to focus on vegetables.
And who knows who's going to be
out there that'll want to come
eat.
And we had set it up so
that if worst came to worst,
I could be the only one in
the restaurant running it.
And then it seems
really roomy, if it's
one person doing all the jobs
in a 350 square foot restaurant.
And what happened, actually,
is we got really busy.
And we were really lucky.
So within the first
couple of months,
we started really filling
up, and then filling up way
too much.
And we kept having
to hire more staff
and trying to get as many
guests into the restaurant as
possible.
So in sort of a
normal restaurant,
you would want to do,
if you have 18 seats,
the most you'd really, really
want to do is about 50.
That's about two and
a half turns, plus.
And we started doing
about 65 people a night,
which meant we were doing
three and a half turns.
And the restaurant
just collapsed.
It couldn't withstand
that many people,
and I had too many staff.
And you'd think with that
number of people coming in
that you would actually
be making money
and it would be a financial
success, but it's not.
I'm not sure the restaurant
really ever made any money.
SPEAKER: Wow.
What a great story.
AMANDA COHEN: It's
a really sad story.
SPEAKER: We talk about
being scrappy at Google,
and using those Easy-Bake
appliances definitely applies
over here.
So when you think about
the landscape of New York
restaurants or even just
restaurants in general,
a lot of the trends
are moving towards
this vegetable-focused cuisine.
How do you think of new ideas?
How do you keep them fresh?
How do you know it's good?
AMANDA COHEN: I
do a lot of drugs.
That's a hard question because
people are always like, oh,
how do you come
up and do dishes?
And honestly, I'm
like, I don't know.
I think of a vegetable,
I think of a flavor,
I think of a place on the menu
where we need to do something,
and then we go through
a lot of testing.
So whatever the idea is in
my head at the beginning,
it looks totally different
when it goes out to a customer
three months later
after all the testing.
We have a broccoli dish.
We have these broccoli hot dogs.
This is an easy example.
And I knew I wanted to do
something with broccoli.
And we had had this sort
of smoked cauliflower
dish on the menu.
People loved it.
It had been on for
about two years.
And I was like,
it's time for that
to go to the island
of retired dishes.
We need to get something new in.
And broccoli was
the right vegetable,
because it has the
same sort of heft.
So it was filling a
position on the menu.
And I really wanted
to do something
with barbecue broccoli.
And we had sort of pulled out--
we had pulled all the stalks
off the broccoli so that there
was just this one single floret
on its long stock.
And we were going to grill
that and-- I don't know.
It was going to get slathered
in a barbecue sauce.
And I wanted to do, like,
five different barbecue sauces
and make it really traditional
and have soft white bread,
but make it broccoli bread.
And I kept testing this
and kept testing this,
and it was disgusting.
It was the most disgusting
thing we've ever made.
And the broccoli bread was foul.
It was like my staff was
like, stop making us eat this.
And I was like, no.
But I think this one's
a little bit better.
And they're like, it's not.
It's just not.
But we had all these components.
And we had made the
broccoli bread into a bun.
And I had sort of had a
temper tantrum, which I'd
like to say I'm exaggerating.
But really, I had had a
temper tantrum in the middle
of the restaurant.
We'd been working
on it for months.
It was a Sunday.
And I literally just took
everything and threw it
in the garbage and maybe
threw some things at the wall
and broke some dishes.
But really, this
is how it happened.
I looked in the garbage,
and the stock of broccoli
sort of fell into the bun.
And I was like, oh, well, that
looks like a broccoli hot dog.
So we went back to
the drawing table,
and we stopped making
the broccoli buns.
We made this soft, white
Japanese milk bread, really,
really soft, as close to
sort of like a fake bun
as you can possibly make.
And then we have
our broccoli stalk
in the middle and the
broccoli sauerkraut
that we put on top
and this mustard sauce
and dehydrated broccoli rob
chips with a little vinegar
powder.
And the dish sort of
rolled out from there.
Now, that dish actually
gave birth to another dish
because the problem with
the broccoli hot dog
is we have that one center
stalk of broccoli, right?
But you get, like, eight
cups of broccoli florets.
So at the little
place, we just ate
a lot of broccoli
for our family meal.
But you have to imagine,
it would be like every day
if you guys went
to the cafeteria,
and the only thing that
was there was broccoli.
You'd revolt.
And we still couldn't
get rid of it.
We had too much.
And so we actually--
I tried to offer it
to all the chefs in
the neighborhood.
And people would take a
quart here or a gallon there.
And then we tried to
actually give it away
to the restaurants in the
neighborhood and be like,
oh, look.
Family meal.
And they're like, yeah, we
can't eat that much broccoli.
And then I actually put up
an ad on Craigslist just
to give away the broccoli.
And that's how we finally
started really getting rid
of it.
There was one woman.
She came and she
would take it all.
And it would be, like, a lot.
Like gallons and gallons
of it, every week.
And we were like, what
is she doing with it?
And we couldn't
actually make a dish
with the broccoli
at little Dirt Candy
because we didn't
have the space.
And so everything that
we did at the little one
was really based on
the space that we had.
How many dishes was the amount
of space we had in the fridge.
How much alcohol we
served was how much space
we had in the drawers under the
banquette where we stored it.
But at the new place,
we have the space.
We have walk-ins and fridges.
So we were like, OK.
Well, we've got to
figure out something
to do with the broccoli.
And that's how we came up with
probably our most popular dish
at the moment, which is our
Korean fried broccoli, which
is a deep fried broccoli dish.
And it's addictive, and people
come all over to have it,
and then they have a second one.
Then they have a third one.
I'm like, oh, my God.
I'm going to have to pay
for your hospital bills
because you're gonna die.
And amazingly, we still
have too much broccoli,
and I'm still giving it away to
a restaurant down the street,
but not as much.
SPEAKER: Broccoli
ice cream, maybe?
Very cool.
So as a chef and
restaurateur, you've
also done some really
amazing things in terms
of eliminating tipping.
So how did you come
to that decision?
What were your key drivers?
And how did you react to some of
the press and people's results?
AMANDA COHEN: So I came to it
for a couple different reasons.
The first was about
three, four years ago,
I put out an ad for a
new cook at Dirt Candy.
And we actually
got zero responses.
And I was like, well,
that's kind of weird.
Because when I had first
opened, the first couple years,
every time I would
put out an ad,
I would get, like,
30, 40 applications.
And I put out a second one, and
a couple people trickled in.
And thankfully, one stuck
around, and we hired them.
But it didn't make
any sense to me.
I have a very niche cuisine.
And there's enough
vegetarian chefs out there.
And we're a well-known
enough restaurant
that we should have
been getting a lot more.
There's only so many
vegetarian restaurants,
but a lot of vegetarian chefs.
So that was sort of
making me think there's
something weird going on.
And I started asking
all my chef friends
if they were noticing
the same problems.
And they were like, oh, yeah.
We're having the hardest
time getting cooks.
And what I sort of realized
was, oh, yeah, of course.
How There's no cooks
left in New York City.
There's a lot of cooks in
cooking schools for students
training to be cooks.
But they're all going
to other cities.
It's really expensive for
them to live in New York.
And they're traveling an
hour, an hour and a half
to get to their job where
they're working 14 hours,
and then traveling back.
And the standard pay
rate is about $10
for a prep cook or line cook.
And you move up, maybe $12.
And sort of the top
you hit is about $15
until you get very specialized.
But at $10, $12, it's
really, really hard
to live in New York.
And so these students
are going to other cities
and now have great restaurants.
There's great food
scenes everywhere else
and a higher standard of living.
It's easier.
So I was like, ah.
Well, I have to fix this
because in the back of my mind,
I'm like, oh I'm about
to open a new restaurant.
And I'm going to need
about 15 more cooks.
What am I going to do?
Well, obviously,
the natural response
is, well, I have
to pay them more.
And that's how I'll attract
them to the restaurant.
But the restaurant doesn't
make that much money.
So margins in restaurants
are really, really small.
Even the best restaurants,
maybe it's, like, 5%.
Most restaurants sort
of hover around 3%.
I run a crappy one,
so it's like 1%.
The money just isn't there.
And we need a lot of labor
for the kind of food I do.
So I was like, OK.
Well, I have to find more money.
But I can't charge more for
what I do because consumers
will only pay so much.
And I was like, all right.
I've got to find this money.
And then I sort of
started looking around.
And I looked at my
server, who I loved.
But she was the only one who
was allowed to take home tips.
And because we were a small
restaurant-- it's 18 seats.
And check average
was about $100.
And if you're doing
60 people a night,
you're pulling in
a lot of money.
And 20% of that is she's walking
out with about $600 a night
on top of the minimum
wage that I'm paying her.
So I was like, oh, yeah.
That is a huge discrepancy.
My line cooks are walking
out with $120, $150,
and she's walking out with $600.
Doesn't mean that I
don't think that she
wasn't working really hard.
But somehow, that
doesn't make sense
if we're all working towards
the same goal in the restaurant.
So I was like, well, maybe I'll
just have my cooks serve more.
And my cooks helped.
They were always helping serve.
My dishwasher was helping serve
more, and I was helping serve.
But none of us can
touch the tips.
So that is this law, that if
you accept the tip credit--
even without the tip credit,
that the only person who
can receive a tip is
the server because they
touch the food basically
80% of the time
once it's left the kitchen.
And that's how it
sort of gets divided.
So then I was like, oh.
Well, I can't take
her tip money away.
That's illegal, and I
don't want to go to jail.
I wouldn't do well in jail.
So I was like, OK.
Well, I have to figure this out.
And then I started
researching into tipping.
And it's a really bad system.
It's sexist.
It's racist.
And it's kind of a false premise
because everybody's like,
oh, yeah.
Well, if the service
is really bad,
then I'm going to
cut my tip in half.
But the truth is most people
just tip what they tip.
If you're a 20% tipper,
you're a 20% tipper,
good service, bad service.
If you do 15%, you're
15% across the board.
And then I started thinking,
this is even weirder
that I'm basically just
letting my customers be
my human resources
department for my server.
They're the ones who are sort
of deciding what she gets paid.
And how does this
even make sense?
Because if I have
a bad night, it's
the server that's
going to get punished.
And when service is really slow
and the food is really bad,
you blame the server.
You don't necessarily
blame the kitchen.
Just all these sort of points
came together in my head.
I was like, all right.
You know what?
Let's get rid of tipping.
Let's see if we
can make this work.
And it was a really good
time because minimum wage
is actually going up for servers
and for regular employees.
So I had to figure
out how I was going
to be able to pay them more.
And yeah, that's
how we came to it.
We started it.
It's pretty amazing
how much people
really hated the idea that we
were getting rid of tipping.
I have been pretty vocal
about a lot of things
that I don't like
in the industry.
But nothing has made people
crazier and hate me more than
getting rid of tipping.
It's like I'm stealing
from my servers.
The bartenders aren't
going to make any money.
How can I make this decision?
This is one of these sort of
strange things that came out,
but I have never got as
much anti-Semitic hate mail
except from this.
I mean, I didn't even know
this really actually existed.
And I was like, oh, my gosh.
You people are mean, saying
mean things about me.
And they were like,
oh, you're so cheap.
You're so awful.
And I was like, well,
I'm not actually cheap.
I'm actually trying to be
really nice to my staff.
And a lot of other restaurateurs
were like, oh, it's
never going to work.
And then it so happened
that it did work.
We haven't gotten rid of it.
Danny Meyer then also went
to his hospitality included,
which really helped us
because it sort of cemented
the fact that this is the
way we think the restaurant
industry is going to move to.
My back off house
is really happy.
They get paid.
And my front of house
is pretty happy.
We get the people who want to
work for a salary, basically.
We are guaranteeing them.
Yes, they could
maybe make $300 one
night in another
restaurant, but they're also
never going to have a
night where they make $100.
So it really sort of
evens out in the end.
And then we did
decide to profit share
because I feel like
for everybody, you
need a little incentive.
Raises, they're sort of far
and few between in restaurants,
especially for the
front of house.
And we wanted to
make it more fun.
And we wanted them to really
understand the economics
and have everybody
feel like they were
working for the restaurant.
So we share 10% of our
profits when we have it.
We don't always
actually have 10%.
But we do our best.
And we have lots of little
incentives along the way.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
So what's next?
What's on the next horizon
of changing the restaurant
landscape?
AMANDA COHEN: I don't know.
That's a tough one.
I don't know what really
is out there next.
We have a really big problem
in the city right now.
Restaurants aren't exactly
sustainable as they are.
Minimum wage is going to go up
in the next couple of years.
It's not going to help the
tiny margins in restaurants.
Rents are incredibly expensive,
just operating a business
in the city.
And it's still really
hard to find labor.
No matter how much I'm
trying to pay my staff,
they're just not here.
And we've sort of had
this-- restaurants
don't charge enough money
for the food they serve.
I know they seem
really expensive.
A lot of labor goes into it.
And it's really
hard to get people
to understand how much it
costs to eat in a restaurant.
And we all think, oh, well,
this plate of those carrots
sliders-- if everybody came to
the cafeteria-- oh, you know,
it's $12.
And that's just a
carrot on a bun.
But the reality is
it's way more work
than just a carrot on a bun.
And on top of that, I'm not
only paying for that labor,
but I'm also paying for the
toilet paper in the bathroom.
And you all want toilet paper
when you come to a restaurant.
I certainly know the people
who steal it want it.
And you also want electricity.
And you want heat in
the winter and air
conditioning in the summer.
And all of that is
really what you're
paying for when you
go to a restaurant.
And we don't charge enough.
So we have to figure
out a way where
we can start
convincing the consumer
that they have to pay a
little bit more money.
Because if not, restaurants
are going to start to close.
And what you'll end
up with is a lot
of those sort of
quick-service restaurants.
Fine dining will disappear.
And that's sort of
the next challenges.
Unfortunately--
or fortunately, I
don't know-- it's educating
the consumer a lot more.
SPEAKER: Do you
think that that's
kind of the solution right now,
just to educate the consumer?
Do you have--
AMANDA COHEN: I mean, that's
the only solution I know.
I've tried my best.
I'm trying so hard to
pay my staff a fair wage.
I want to be able
to pay them more.
In two years, everybody who
walks into the restaurant
starts off at $15 an hour
unless you're a server, where
you make a little bit more.
And in a couple
years, that's actually
just going to be minimum wage.
So I now have to
figure out a way where
I can pay them $20 an hour.
I can get that up.
Well, I have to be able to
charge more for the food.
I have to find the
money somewhere.
So yeah, that is the
only solution I know.
SPEAKER: Yeah, definitely.
We'd love to shift
gears a little
and talk about your cookbook.
So what made you decide to
one, write a cookbook, but two,
make it a comic,
graphic novel cookbook?
AMANDA COHEN: Well, I
really didn't really
want to write a cookbook.
And I had worked for a
number of restaurants
where sort of within the
first year, the chefs
had disappeared to
write a cookbook.
And I was like, that sucks.
Because you're not
there, and nobody's
taking care of the restaurant.
And the restaurant really hadn't
been around enough, I thought,
to tell a story.
But I'm also a snob and
have a lot of opinions.
What do I know?
So we had gotten approached
a couple of times
by some editors and
publishers that were like,
oh, we really want you
to write a cookbook.
We really want you
And I was like, no, no, no.
And then sort of
one day, it sunk in.
And I was like, well, maybe.
But I don't want to
write a regular cookbook.
I love cookbooks, and I
have a huge collection,
but I'm not sure people actually
cook from cookbooks so much
anymore.
There's the internet.
I think most people
look online for recipes.
And that's where they
really cook from.
And cookbooks have become more
like picture books and coffee
table books.
And I was like, that's not
really representative of what
we do at the restaurant.
And if we're going
do a cookbook,
we have to make
something really fun.
So I had-- I don't know.
I was having some huge
fight with my husband.
And he was like, are
you going to do this?
And I'm like, I don't
want to do this.
It's not going to be fun.
And he's like, well,
let's make it fun.
I was like, I don't
know how to make it fun.
I was like, we'd have to
do something really stupid.
And he was like, yeah, like
do it in a comic book form.
And then we both stopped dead.
And we actually sort of
were having this fight
in the middle of the street.
So traffic had stopped, too.
And we stopped.
And we were like, oh, yeah.
That's perfect.
And it just clicked
right away because we
knew that if we found
the right artist,
we could really
capture the spirit
of the restaurant in this book.
Little Dirt Candy was
crazy and was insane
and was like a circus
every single night.
And I couldn't figure out how I
could just do that in pictures.
But with sort of the
movement that you
get in a graphic novel, we
really were like, oh, yeah.
We could really
make this happen.
We can make these
characters come alive,
and we could tell the
story of the restaurant.
And then we could
also sort of rework
how recipes were written.
I think it's really
easy to learn
something visually
and not always
when there's a lot of words next
to it, especially with cooking.
And we were like, oh, yeah.
We could draw out
so much of this
and make it seem so real that
it would make a lot of sense
to the person who's
cooking from it.
And these aren't easy
recipes, so we really
wanted to make them as easy
as possible for the reader.
So we went back to all the
editors and publishers who
had come to us,
and we were like,
oh, we're totally going
to write a cookbook.
We have this great idea.
And they're like, no.
Absolutely not.
And we were like, no,
but it's going to be--
and they were like, no.
Way too much work.
And we found Clarkson
Potter, Random House.
They took us on.
And we worked with
them to do this.
And it was amazing.
I'm not an artist whatsoever.
But Ryan Dunlavey, who
was the graphic artist,
he did this amazing job
of just really capturing
the essence of the
restaurant and making
it look alive and fun.
And we told the
story through it.
And everybody said
that it wouldn't sell.
And so our first run, I
think, was about 5,000 copies.
And within, like, a month, we
had gone into the second run.
And we're about
40,000 copies now,
which for a cookbook without
a big name attached to
it is good.
SPEAKER: Wow, that's awesome.
AMANDA COHEN: I still
haven't made back
any royalties, though, yet.
I'm waiting for that.
SPEAKER: Maybe after this.
No, that's awesome.
So we also know
you were on "Iron
Chef," as mentioned before.
How was that experience?
What is the 411,
inside scoop that they
don't show you on Food Network?
AMANDA COHEN: Actually,
the biggest surprise
was how long it
took-- not the battle.
The battle is real.
It's that 60 minutes,
and it is crazy.
I don't remember
most of it because it
happened in such a blur.
But the judging takes
a really long time.
So it's actually four hours.
And by the end, you're
like, I don't care who wins.
I just want to go home.
I've been here since 7:00 AM.
I want to go home.
The whole experience
was pretty crazy.
Sort of like everything in
my life, I said no to it.
And then they're
like, are you sure?
And I was like, I don't know.
I'm just gonna go and
look like a loser.
And I'm gonna lose.
And they were like,
no, you're not.
And I was like,
yeah, I probably am.
And I was like, I don't
want to look dumb.
And we had to agree
that it would definitely
be a vegetarian battle.
And you get there,
and it's just a lot
of bright lights and camera
people all around you.
And the hardest thing
is that Iron Chef really
knows where everything is.
They've been there.
They've done it.
They're allowed in the kitchen.
So they stock their fridges
the way they want to stock it.
They know how the stoves
work and the blenders work
and the ice cream machine.
And as the competitor, you
walk in, and you're like,
I don't know.
Where's the fridge?
And they're like, that thing.
And you're like, oh, I
thought that was the freezer.
I thought that was the stove.
None of it really makes sense.
So in those 60 minutes
when you're cooking,
you're looking for things.
Half the time is like, ah!
Where am I?
And you're doing that as some
camera guy is following you
around.
You're like, I feel crazy!
And then the Iron Chef, they
know where everything is.
And so they're very calm.
I did exactly what they
told me I was going to do,
which is they're like, oh, yeah.
You're the chef, so you
probably don't cook a lot.
I was like, I'm in my
kitchen every night.
And they're like,
yeah, just be careful.
You're probably going
to cut yourself.
And I was like, I'm
not gonna cut myself.
Like, two seconds into it, I was
like, my finger's hanging off!
So in the whole
show, I had Band-Aids
that kept falling off.
And I was like, it
stopped bleeding!
I can keep the Band-Aid off!
And they're like,
no, continuity.
I was like, ah!
So every three seconds,
I had a new Band-Aid on.
SPEAKER: Stick to the plot.
AMANDA COHEN: And then for us,
the-- we're dumb, all of us.
I love my people who work in
my restaurant, me included,
but we just didn't quite get
what we were supposed to do.
And they were like,
well, it's five courses.
And we were like, yeah,
it's five courses.
And I don't know what was
actually wrong with our brains.
But we made enough food for
like a night in the dining room.
But really, it's only
the judges who sit there.
And it's like three people
taking tiny little bites.
They were all,
like, [INAUDIBLE].
Tiny little sizes.
And we realized that's really
what Chef Morimoto did.
They make these tiny
little portions.
Meanwhile, we made, like, a
gallon of beurre blanc sauce.
And they were like,
what are you going to do
with all this butter sauce?
I'm like, I don't know.
SPEAKER: Put it on Craigslist.
AMANDA COHEN: Put
it on Craigslist.
So we spent a lot of time
doing stupid stuff like that.
And I would like
to say that we won.
But we did not win.
But we did a good showing.
And it was fun.
I would never do it again.
I'm not a competitive
person like that.
But it was really,
really fun to do,
and I'm glad I have
it on my resume.
SPEAKER: That is awesome.
What a cool story.
So we'll actually
be taking questions
in the next few minutes.
So if anyone has a question,
start to think about it
and head to the mics.
We'd love to just hear a little
quickfire-- what is the best
thing you've ever eaten?
AMANDA COHEN: I hope I
haven't eaten it yet.
SPEAKER: Oh.
What is your favorite
vegetable and why?
AMANDA COHEN: Um--
SPEAKER: I know, it's
like all your kids.
AMANDA COHEN: Actually,
this is-- an onion.
It's actually my
favorite vegetable.
It's really really versatile,
and it's the backbone
of almost every single dish.
So we couldn't live
without it in the kitchen.
I mean, I don't usually
eat them like an apple,
although sometimes
they're really sweet.
But that is, it works
so hard in the kitchen,
and it gets such little love.
SPEAKER: That's a great one.
Any particular onion that
you like better than others?
AMANDA COHEN: No, no.
I'm an onion lover.
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: What's your favorite
thing to do to relax?
AMANDA COHEN: Actually,
just read a book by myself,
not talk to anybody.
SPEAKER: That's awesome.
OK, cool.
Well, any questions?
Oh, looks like we do have one.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So what are the tax implications
of the gratuity-only model?
And I was also
curious if you see
any way of changing
the laws to make
it easier for
restaurants to do what
you're doing in that regard.
AMANDA COHEN: The tax
implications for me,
personally, as a business, it
doesn't make a big difference.
My insurance has gone up a lot
because my payroll has gone up
a lot.
So that's the biggest
difference cost to me.
Tax implications
are for the consumer
because now you're
getting taxed on your tip.
Right?
So sales tax for the
consumer has gone up.
But it's also only gone
up slightly because you
used to pay sales
tax on, let's say,
the $100 portion of your bill.
And now you're
paying it on $120,
but it's really only that
differential on the $20.
The laws are there to make
what I'm doing actually best
for everybody.
The laws surrounding
tipping are so complicated.
And even without meaning to,
people break them constantly.
And it's funny things
you wouldn't think of.
Bussers-- this is sort of what
most of the lawsuits, if you've
ever read the sort of
food gossip papers,
there's all these lawsuits
against restaurants and tipping
and who gets paid what.
Well, the easiest
way to understand
them is bussers who
spend more than 20%
of their time polishing
are entitled to the tips.
And that's part of
their job, right?
So then you have to be like,
OK, [? Russal ?], you've
been polishing for
an hour, and you've
got to get back on the floor.
I've got to switch you
off with somebody else.
And even if he's like, but
I like doing the polishing,
he's not entitled to the tips.
So the law actually
works against tipping.
It works for exactly
what I'm doing,
which is paying
everybody a fair wage
and not having to sort of be
a part of that tipping system.
It would be nicer if-- yeah,
the way we do get hit a little
is on our state taxes for
employees, like FUDA and SUDA.
That would be nice if
those were reduced a little
because we're getting
hit with that.
And if you weren't part
of the tip credit system,
if there was some other
credit system but you
were paying your
employees a fair wage.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER: Very interesting.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering
if you could talk
a little bit about
vegetarianism,
both kind of your personal
philosophy towards it
and then the role that you think
it kind of plays or should play
in the food scene in
general, especially as there
are more vegetarian or
vegetable-focused restaurants
opening.
AMANDA COHEN: Well,
I'm not a vegetarian.
I was one for about
maybe 15 years or so.
And I gave it up
because I just had
gone to-- I was really tired
of the vegetarian plate
at restaurants, to be honest.
I was like, I can't eat any more
grilled portabellas and a side
of rice, even at
fancy restaurants.
If I'm going out
to eat, I'm really
not becoming a better chef.
Obviously, other
chefs just really care
about the protein on the
plate and not the vegetable.
That was about 15 years ago.
And times have changed.
But for me, I'm not
a vegetarian anymore.
And I really became a vegetarian
because I don't like meat.
So it's just a personal
taste preference.
I've never really missed it.
I do think the world's
diet is changing.
I think people want to
eat more vegetables.
I still think they
really want to eat meat.
And it's all about
finding the balance.
So I think restaurants
like mine that
are really
vegetable-focused are always
going to be a smaller proportion
of the restaurants out there.
But the more people can offer
vegetables, the more exciting
it is.
And we're starting to see some
really exciting things happen,
particularly in New York
City, where people are now
getting used to eating their
vegetables at restaurants.
It doesn't seem so awful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: What's your favorite
dish on your menu right now?
AMANDA COHEN: Probably
the carrot sliders,
which is what we
served downstairs.
And also, we have this pepper
dish, which is delicious.
But mostly I like it because
it's really, really annoying
to my staff to have to make.
And they have to do it.
And we take bell peppers,
and we filet them.
So we peel off one side of the
skin and peel off the other,
and then we punch a
lot of holes out of it
so they look lifesavers.
And it's a lot of work, and
they're really angry at me.
So I find that pleasurable.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
We'll take a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So Dirt Candy is a
really great name
for a restaurant that's
focused on vegetables.
I wonder if you had
any sort of story
about how you came up with
that name and its origins.
AMANDA COHEN: Well, again, it
was a fight between my husband
and I. So we were
trying to figure out
what to name the restaurant.
And we wanted to stay away
from a one-word restaurant
name, really because-- and
this is weird to say here--
it's really hard to google it.
If you're called Fork, and
you just put in "fork,"
everything shows up,
from actual forks--
like a fork in the road-- to a
million other restaurants named
Fork.
So that was out.
And we were trying
to really figure out
what the restaurant represented,
what vegetables represented.
And as things escalate, we were
fighting about what they meant
and what they were.
And at one point, I
was like, no, they're
like candy from the earth.
And my husband was
like, dirt candy!
And we both stopped, and
we were like, oh, yeah.
Dirt Candy.
That's good.
That's really, really good.
And then before
we had opened, we
thought we were going to be
more of a vegetable and fruit
restaurant.
So we were like, well if we
call ourselves Dirt Candy,
we can be Dirt
Candy and Tree Meat.
And then we both stopped, and
we were like, no tree meat.
We cannot call a
restaurant Tree Meat,
although I still really like it.
And then we sort
of went from there.
We were like, yeah Dirt Candy.
It's perfect.
And then I actually went to
go buy Dirt Candy, the name,
and it was taken.
That's why I'm dirtcandynyc.com.
And it actually pulled up
my other favorite name,
not necessarily for a
restaurant but for a project
that one day I want
to work on, which
is nastybonbons.com, which would
be [INAUDIBLE] sister to Dirt
Candy.
So I should have bought it.
I really like
that, nastybonbons.
And so we took Dirt Candy.
And we knew it was going to be a
difficult name for some people.
And we did.
I mean, still to this day, eight
years later, two restaurants,
and countless reviews, we
are still getting, well,
that's the worst name
for a restaurant.
And I'm like, I don't really
care because you remember it.
And you will never forget it.
And so we branded
ourselves with this name.
SPEAKER: How do you deal with
criticism and people constantly
critiquing your food?
AMANDA COHEN: I cry a lot.
I cry by myself in the bathroom.
I try not to read the reviews.
And then I'm totally
lying, because I read them,
which everybody does.
I now have other
people who read them,
and they sort of
filter it out for me.
The truth is, it's hard.
It's really hard.
We all work really hard.
I'm in the restaurant
every single day.
My team is in the restaurant.
And we have staff meetings.
We do our best to
do customer service.
We're constantly asking
people how things are
or what else we can do for them.
And when you read
something the next day
where it's really
negative, and you're like,
but I was right there.
Why didn't you say
something to me
in person where I can fix it?
I can't fix it if
you've left, really.
I can offer to
refund your meal if I
can get an email address
or a phone number.
But the truth is, I
want to help you there.
My goal, even though I am a
chef and, yes, I have an ego,
is I'm a restaurateur.
And I want to give you the
best customer service possible.
And I want to sure you
have the best experience.
And such a small part
of going to a restaurant
is about the food.
It's about the company
and the service
and everything else
that makes it up.
And that's my job, is to make
you really, really happy.
Hopefully, I can make
you love the food, too.
You might not like
it, and that's OK.
My food is definitely
not for everybody.
But the experience is
what I want you to have.
And it's really, really
hurtful, actually,
when we read negative reviews
because we're like, well,
we're right there.
You could have said something.
You thought this was too salty?
I'm so sorry.
We would have remade it.
Or you didn't like
this, or you thought
you weren't getting
paid enough attention.
Whatever the thing is, I can
only fix it at the moment.
SPEAKER: For sure.
Definitely.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
First of all, the carrot
sliders were really good.
Had one for lunch.
So thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE]
AMANDA COHEN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: They were
super delicious.
And next, I was thinking
about all the challenges
of having a restaurant in
New York City that you talked
about-- how expensive it is, and
how hard it is to get staffed.
I'm wondering if you've ever
think about leaving New York
and setting up shop
somewhere else?
And if you don't, why you
stay in New York City?
And if you do, where you'd go?
AMANDA COHEN: I stay because
I have a 10-year lease, which
I can't get out of.
Also, I live here.
This is my home.
I've been here
for over 20 years.
I love, love the city.
But it wasn't this
hard beforehand.
And it's become really
hard and really expensive
over the last couple of years.
And I probably will never
open another restaurant
in New York City.
It's just financially--
I don't know how
people afford to do it, really.
So if I were to go somewhere
else, I would probably go home.
I'd probably maybe open
another place in Toronto, which
is where my entire family is.
It would be nice to spend
some time with them.
But I'm not sure I want to
ever open another restaurant.
It's a lot of work,
and I'm getting old.
I don't want to stand
that long anymore.
I've been standing for 15
hours a day for about 20 years.
I'm tired.
Restaurants are really,
really hard work.
AUDIENCE: So it's
been fascinating,
as someone who likes
going to restaurants,
to hear about your
experiences and your opinions.
I was really curious
about what do
you think about
takeout and delivery
because that's a big thing here.
I wonder what you as a
restaurateur think about that?
AMANDA COHEN: I mean,
I think it's great
because I eat it when I'm
not working all the time.
So thank goodness for Seamless.
I don't know what I would do.
It's almost like
takeout and delivery,
it's like they're
two different foods.
It's like they're not the same.
We can't do delivery
from Dirt Candy
because our portions only look
normal sized in the restaurant.
I don't know if it's because
of the plate size or what,
but when we pack it up
when somebody's like, oh,
I'll take that to go,
we're always like, huh.
How did that fit in that
tiny little container,
but we spent three
weeks making it?
So it is really,
really different.
The takeout model,
though, and delivery
and all those sort of
quick-service restaurants
are great.
And they have found this way
to make portions decent sized.
They get you
through fast enough,
and its sort of that
satisfying comfort moment.
But it's really,
really different
than going out to
eat at a restaurant.
And I do think because people--
especially in New York,
there is so much
takeout and delivery.
It changes your expectations
at a restaurant.
You forget that you're
there for the experience
and to be there with company
and to have a bottle of wine
or cocktails or whatever
it is and really sit
and enjoy the moment versus
getting something really
fast and eating it at your
desk or in front of the TV
and being finished with it.
And because there are so
many takeout and delivery
kind of places, it
has, I do think,
changed the way people
eat in restaurants.
SPEAKER: Yeah, for sure.
Any other questions
before we wrap up?
Go for it.
Oh, wait-- what's your
go-to Seamless order?
I have to ask.
AMANDA COHEN: Well, we have
a lot of fights about it.
You know what's hard?
Every time we find a
restaurant we really like,
I swear the next
week, it's gone.
I'm like, what happened to you?
We have a Thai place on our
corner that's pretty good.
And then I feel really bad
saying it's on our corner.
I'm like, how can I not go
out and pick it up myself?
It's like a block
and a half away.
But I'm still like, no.
You got to come.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was
wondering whether, as running
a vegetarian restaurant, you
feel that there's a pricing
pressure where
customers in New York
are willing to pay more if
there's a fancy piece of meat
on the plate than
they will if you put
even more labor into making
a really nice vegetable,
but they say, oh,
it's just a vegetable.
I don't need to pay for it.
AMANDA COHEN: Are
you in my brain?
Yeah.
I mean, that's
actually, I think,
one of the really big
problems with the restaurant.
We sort of have
this price point we
can't go above, which
is, like, $22, $23.
That's sort of the cutoff point.
After that, we will
see in reviews,
oh, I'm not going to pay
that much for this food.
But I do think if I had that
same dish at a steakhouse,
I could probably charge $30,
and nobody would sort of
think twice about it.
It is where you're
eating and what's
sort of getting
served next to it.
One of the really hard
things with vegetables--
and this is my fault.
It's my restaurant.
It's what I do.
But they are really
labor intensive.
And if you think like, oh,
I put a whole piece of meat
in the oven, and I just cook it.
Well, every single carrot has to
be peeled and diced and cooked
and done something else to it.
And so that labor
difference is huge.
People walk into my kitchen
and be like, oh, my God.
There are so many of you here.
I'm like, I know,
I'm so embarrassed.
I'm like, why am I embarrassed?
So just that difference, yeah.
I mean, I truly believe if I
put a piece of fish on my menu,
I could raise all my menus
by a couple of dollars
and everybody would be
like, yeah, of course.
She serves fish.
Nobody would order it.
But I would have it.
Like, oh it's that
fish restaurant
with lots of vegetables.
She can charge $30 a plate.
SPEAKER: What's your
view on local produce
versus organic produce?
I feel like a lot
of the times now,
it's a lot of farm to table.
Do you feel like that's a
really important element
to have in a restaurant
or your restaurant?
Or are you comfortable
with any type of vegetable?
AMANDA COHEN: I'm comfortable
with any type of vegetable.
If you can afford it and you
want to buy organic, great.
I can't.
My prices would be
ridiculously high.
We do some organic stuff.
A lot of our dairy is,
half of our dry goods,
and certain produce items.
But for the most
part, we're not.
Local when it's
in season, great.
But we live in the Northeast.
I wrote a whole
piece about tomatoes
and how if you want a
tomato, just go buy it.
Don't feel guilty.
Better to eat a tomato
than something else
in the middle of winter.
All food comes off a truck
in a box somewhere, anyways.
We have a big enough
problem in this country
that people don't eat
enough vegetables.
New York might be sort
of outside of that,
but the USDA statistics for
how much vegetables are eaten
are really, really
depressing in this country.
And the two most
popular vegetables
are potato and tomato because
it's French fries and ketchup.
So I'm like, yeah, I'm not
sure local is the issue.
I'm just getting people
to eat vegetables.
So yeah, when we
can, we buy local.
But we can't always,
and my goal is
to get people to eat
their vegetables.
And once I can get
them to do that,
maybe I'll try a little
harder with other things.
SPEAKER: Cool.
Awesome.
We'll take one more question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I live in the Lower East Side.
I was wondering
if you could talk
a little bit about your
choice of location and kind
of the restaurant scene in
Lower East Side and sort
of how you feel it compares
to other parts of the city
and stuff like that?
AMANDA COHEN: I've
only ever owned
a restaurant in the East
Village or the Lower East
Side-- totally
different neighborhoods.
They're actually very similar.
The thing with the
Lower East Side
is it's probably one
of the last areas
where you can get a
good deal on rent.
And that's why I chose it.
Rent is really expensive
in New York right now.
So for my small space,
which was 350 square feet,
my rent started off
at $1,800, which
was really fair and decent.
And eight years later,
it was at $4,000.
SPEAKER: Wow.
AMANDA COHEN: So those numbers
just don't make any sense.
Now, 10 blocks south, which is
where I am in Lower East Side,
I have about 2,500 square
feet, and my rent is $10,000.
So that makes a lot more sense.
And there you can still
get really good rent deals.
The restaurant scene, I
think, in the Lower East Side
is the most exciting.
The restaurants are really nice.
I loved being in
the East Village.
But I don't know, they
were mean over there.
Nobody wanted to
take my broccoli.
In the Lower East Side,
everybody's taking it.
No, they're really nice, and
we have a really nice community
of restaurants.
And I think the food
scene is exciting.
And I think because
the rents are cheaper
and you can sort
of make a living,
people are more willing
to take chances.
And so it's a lot of fun.
There's just this really young,
vibrant feeling down there.
Other neighborhoods in the city
to me seem really stagnant.
It seems like it's the same
restaurant opening over again.
And I think in the
Lower East Side,
you get to see a little
bit more diversity.
SPEAKER: Super cool.
All right.
Well, that is it.
Everyone should go stop by Dirt
Candy and make a reservation.
AMANDA COHEN: Please do.
SPEAKER: At 86 Allen Street.
We also have some
comic book cookbooks
for sale, Googler
discount, for $5.
So feel free to grab
one after the talk.
Amanda, thank you
so much for coming.
The food was amazing.
And I know I can
speak for myself
and everyone else-- this
talk has been awesome.
AMANDA COHEN: Good.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
AMANDA COHEN: Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE]